We want a season sorry I never showed up, but I got married I had a baby I went back to school got my GE-e-D
What did you do while you were waiting? Hopefully you didn't just around and waste your life
Ooooweee see you for season four in like a really long time
I might even have a big white Santa Claus beard see you see then
Hey everybody this is gonna be my first season for video talking about all the stuff
That's coming back what the writers have said behind the scenes and things that have actually been
Confirmed along with what the Rick and Morty video schedule is gonna be during the off season there will be weekly Rick and Morty
I'll still be doing the weekly giveaway
And if there are any other TV series or things you want me to do videos for let me know in the comments
But be sure to subscribe to get everything
So starting off with the big things first a lot of people are asking about the Santa Claus episode theory so mr.
says that he might have a big white Santa Claus beard when he comes back like there might be a Christmas episode
BBC Doctor Who style the BBC is just known for doing special one-off
Christmas episodes for a lot of its biggest drama series
So I think largely based on that and the idea that they did the April Fool's Day
Special episode like they aired it as a one-off
They might do something like that again when season four comes back
But there hasn't been any indication from the writers that that's their intention
This is actually something that one of the writers said like don't people get tired of being wrong about stuff like this like he's saying
That they're probably not intending to do that this will get into where they are in their season for production because if they actually did
Have a season four episode that would air this Christmas that means they would have had to send it off for
Animation before the summer even started it takes at least six months to animate most episodes
So this is actually a pretty clear timeline once they finish writing and recording
Episodes and send them off to be animated but based on previous experience in the way they treat
Characters that they bring back and big ongoing storylines some of these are actually pretty easy
So I'll just count down from 10 so number 10. We're staying in the same reality. That's probably the most obvious thing
That's why they kept saying in the episode that jumping to another reality would be a super-huge bitch
And why Rick had to become fake?
Fly-fishing Rick at the end of the episode so that he could stay in this reality and function the way that he had previously
but just like they did in season 3 episode 1 season 4 episode 1
We'll probably just have a quick line of dialogue about all the craziness that happened during season 3 and what they've been doing since then
Number 9. They're not gonna go back to Beth being a clone versus being real
They're probably never address it again in a really big way maybe a joke here there
But the whole idea with that line of dialogue that she has is that Rick would never tell us
And he's not gonna kill her so regardless of where you fall in that spectrum
She's just gonna be treated like the main version of Beth
But number 8 Rick's status in the family like they say everything's being reset to season 1
He'll continue to be treated as the lowest status member so at the beginning of season 3 he sort of took control the family
This is them
resetting that back to the beginning of season 1
So the end result of that is that Rick will get to do whatever he wants to do morty and summer will
Continue to be allowed to go on potentially life-threatening adventures and Beth isn't gonna
take him to task about it Jerry might not be happy about it like he wasn't happy during season 1
But Dan Harmon explained a long time ago part of the core concept of the show is that Beth?
Idolizes Rick so she hopes that someday Morty might turn into a Rick
Which is why she allows him to go on these adventures with him
But Morty just continuing the theme of him slowly getting older or getting
Smarter will just continue to be more assertive with Rick now
Even if you play it fast and loose with how much older he's getting on the show like The Simpsons for instance are
Perpetually stuck at their current age, but it seems like Rick and Morty is actually moving in real time
So like he gets a little bit older each season even though they don't directly address it that much we saw his 13th birthday
So if he was 14 around season 1 he should be at least approaching the age of 17
But that kind of seems like where summer is so I'm assuming they're just getting a little fast and loose with how old they get
But you still have to assume that
Off-screen Rick is still using that memory gun every once in a while like they might never go back to that room
But it's just an easy way for them to control his rate of development because otherwise he would probably go crazy
Instantly like he wanted to kill himself after he got all memories back
and that's just after the previous seasons not after anything that might end up happening during season four and there's all these adventures that we
Don't wind up seeing like you have to assume that they go on adventures all the time in between episodes
Let's go 20 minutes adventure
But just like we saw new secret rooms and new secret gadgets sort of emerge out of nowhere
Doctor Who style inside Rick's lab
we'll probably see more of that in season four usually what that ends up being just
Depends on the story that they want to tell like is either a room full of Rick clones
Or it's a room full of memories so whatever stories
They want to tell during season four
they'll just create another room for that or other gadgets like the squirrel gadget that pops up out of nowhere out of the table or
any of the weapons or things that he has hidden around the house you have to assume that there's more of that that we just
Haven't seen yet
Just because they haven't needed it for a story, but even though they rolled back the Beth Jeri divorce thing
And it seems like they're together now
I think they'll slowly slide back to their dynamic in season one where she sort of resents him just a little bit
But they're still in somewhat of a loving relationship
But Dan Harmon did say something funny about his own parents like a lot of Beth Jeri
Divorce stuff is based on his own experience in real life with his parents who got divorced and then later got back together
But mr.
Poopy butthole the meeseeks squatchy will all come back in various roundabout ways like we saw meeseeks during that Star Trek
parody
But they didn't actually like physically come back in a legit episode and the same thing with squatchy - like he's mostly connected to that
Federation storyline so if we see him again it might just be in a picture or a memory mr
Poopy butthole style like we got that post-credits end tag with him
But that was mostly a funny riff on the season two post-credits scene that wasn't them bringing him in like the Total Recall
Episode where he was a really fundamental part of the narrative
Thanks mr.. Poopy butthole I always could count on you, but the interesting thing. I think about this too
Is they haven't revealed whether or not they always plan to tag him at the end of this episode?
Sort of setting up a delay for season four like Oh see you in a very very long time
Or if that's just a way for them to sort of wink at the idea that it took forever to get to season three buts
Of people coming back phoenix person and Tammy we didn't see them again after
Episode one so at some point they're still alive they're still stuck in this reality that we're currently in so they're around there somewhere in
The universe but the whole point of that story during the first episode was to sort of table that ongoing
Season 1 season 2 narrative of the Federation trying to get his portal technology like saying that okay?
We're done with this storyline so when they do come back. It'll be a little bit different
They'll still want to take Rick down and they still probably want access to other realities
But it'll have to be a little more insidious because he took out a large portion of their fleet
So there's a couple of them left and now really the big
Ethereal threat in the multiverse is evil Morty so obviously evil Morty will come back in some way
He'd already upended the power structure between Morty's and their Rick's on the Citadel even without moving directly against
C-137 Rick he'll probably continue to try and spread that paradigm throughout the multiverse so the more Morty's you have being assertive in
Distracting their Rick's the fewer Rick's there are to figure out
What evil Morty is doing and stop him so I think there'll be a lot of chaos going on in the background and we can
Make all kinds of theories about evil Morty forming an alliance with Phoenix person and Tammy, but I think when they do come back
They'll come back separately before they come back together
If that is really where they're headed
but really the first big one you guys will like this so season four will be 14 episodes like we were promised in season 3
Technically so Dan Harmon actually explained that originally, they'd intended for season 3 to be 14 episodes
But because of the delay they had to adjust their plans so
Because of all the changes they made behind the scenes to get season 4 out faster. He said what they're gonna
Do is they'll deliver the first 10 episodes that they would normally?
Deliver to Adult Swim then go back to them and say here the other 4 episodes that we want to do this season I've already
Addressed that Christmas episode theory so if it does take them a little bit longer than next summer to get episodes out
It's because they're doing that extra 4 so remember it takes about six months to animated an episode the writers finished writing
season 3 last
October they went on like a probably brief hiatus then came back and started writing season 4 so they've actually been writing
Season 4 or scripts this entire year like literally this entire time. We've been waiting to get episodes
They've actually already been working on season four the whole reason why Adult Swim hasn't confirmed
When season four is coming or even that it's coming at all is because Dan Harmon and Justin roiland
Contracts were up at Adult Swim, so while I think it'll all work out
We will get our season four they really want to give it to us
They just have to figure out the business stuff behind the scenes and once that's locked down then they'll say okay
We're working on season four and they'll start tweeting stuff out
but what will happen next is I'll do a Q&A video so
Anything you have about season four or stuff from season three you want me to include in that just write it in the comments below
And that'll post tomorrow during the off season what I'll probably do is
I'll at least be doing Rick and Morty on Saturdays and once or twice during the week
But I'll be doing theory videos any news that drops about season four or anything from behind the scenes or things that they release so
If you have special requests, just let me know in the comments
And if there are other TV series that you want me to do videos for just let me know
But the weekly giveaway will continue right now. It's for the Zen monkey studios merch
It'll be for the season 3 DVD when they announce that's coming out so as soon as that hits pre-order
That's what the giveaway will be for all you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber
Leave a comment on this video congratulations to the winner from the last video Derrick stall
Please private message me so I can get your contact details you can click here for my finale video
And you can click here to start getting ready for the blast season 4 which is coming back next week
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight